on va passer à l'invité du soir on va
parler de l'hydroxychloroine il y a
quelques jours une étude française est
sortie elle a révélé que son utilisation
pour avoir provoqué près de 17000 décès
en 5 mois souvenez-vous ce traitement
avait été promu par le professeur Didier
raou pendant la première vague de la
pandémie du covid en 2020 il va nous
donner son avis sur le sujet et on va en
parler aussi tiens je vais avoir
j'aimerais bien avoir l'avis de Myriam
Palomba parce que c'est vrai que tu es
également spécialiste tu es spécialiste
covid hein en plus d'être spécialiste
people c'est jus de fruits et
covid on regarde
et le professeur est avec nous juste
après on va l'installer tout de suite
professeur RA merci c'est parti regarde
pour certains en plein covid c'était la
molécule miracle
l'hydroxychlorokine le professeur Didier
raou en était l'apôtre à l'IHU de
Marseille consulté comme un oracle par
Emmanuel Macron lui-même en pleine
première vague en avril 2020 pour des
chercheurs lyonnais au contraire c'était
surtout un traitement à haut risque sa
prescription aurait augmenté la
mortalité des patients atteints du covid
de 11 % on a pu estimer le nombre de
morts imputable à l'utilisation de ce
médicament environ 17000 morts une
projection qui sous-estime sans doute le
nombre de victimes pourquoi France
Belgique Italie Espagne Turquie et
États-Unis seulement 6 pays sont pris en
compte merci professeur raou d'être avec
nous merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
plateau c'est toujours un plaisir de
vous recevoir ni Diou ni angélique ni
diabolique les antibiotiques déjà je
vouis vous remercier pour le petit mot
que vous avez mis à la suite du du
complément d'enquête que j'ai lu
d'ailleurs à l'antenne qui m'a bien fait
rire euh comment allez-vous très bien
demande t quand vous allez parce que ça
m'intéresse les autres invités je m'en
fous euh non ça vous allez bien très
bien ils ont pas fini de vous ememberder
hein ça ça ça ça pas d'importance je
vais vous dire non le le j'ai j'ai une
grande théorie que que j'essaie de
d'expliquer aux gens qui travaillent
avec moi c'est que vous savez le les
ennuis et les les les hostilité vous
vous oblige vous vous vous me
pardonnerez de me faire des compliments
momême vous obligez à être intelligent
donc chaque moi ça
m'amuseou ça vous amuse c'est comme moi
ouais ça m'amuse je suis con comme une
mais bon mais vous ça vous am que
vous êtes intelligent vous dit je vais
je vais vous
expliquer comment on a réagi nous à
cette non cette étude je m'en fous je
vous expliquerai à la fin c'est une
c'est une
bêtise nous comment on a défini et
solidifié la manière dont on a
TR on a reçu 250000 personnes je sais
pas si vous voyez ce que c'est que
250000 personnes sont venu se faire
tester à l'U sur ces 250000 personnes il
a fallu on a eu plein de volontaires
donc beaucoup d'émigrés d'ailleurs je je
veux insister sur le fait qu'il y avait
une quantité d'émigrés qui sont venus
nous aider qui a été considérable et
qu'on naurait pas pu soigner les
Français à Marseille si on nait pas eu
les émigrés c'est c'est une une apparté
d'actualité vous me
pardonnerez
deuxièmement donc parce que il fallait
rappeler les gens on voulait rappeler
les gens dans les heures qui suivaient
pour leur donner le résultat du test
est-ce que c'est positif est-ce que
c'est négatif quand c'était positif on
leur disait venez si vous on va vous
donner des conseils si vous voulez qu'on
vous soigne on vous soignera donc les
250000coute bien c'est très intéressant
de mon point de vue ça a été notre
réponse à tout ça les 250000 personnes
qui sont venues ont pris ont eu un test
se sont enregistrés et ont été
enregistrés non pas à l'IHU l'IHU est
une sous-partie du CHU de Marseille et
de gens qui nous aiment pas
particulièrement pour dire la vérité
donc ils ont pas d'intérêt à tricher
pour nous et donc on a le listing
complet de tous les gens qui sont venus
se faire tester on a tous les gens qui
sont venus se faire traiter à l'hôpital
bien entendu ont été enregistrés à
l'hôpital en hôpital de jouron en
hospitalisation en hospitalisation quand
ils étaient en très mauvais état et en
partie quand il quand ils avaient besoin
d'oxygène et nous avons aussi le
registre dans le CHU de tous les gens
qui ont été hospitalisés on peut pas
être hospitalisé en cachette
d'accord pour savoir ce que les gens
avaient reçu comme traitement quand on
est à l'hôpital dans un monde normal
après je vous parlerai du monde des fous
dans dans un monde normal on fait une
ordonnance et cette ordonnance c'est pas
nous qui la traitons c'est la Pharmacie
centrale du CHU d'accord donc on a
envoyé le nom des 34000 personnes
heureusement il y a un pharmacien très
dynamique qui a regardé quel était le
traitement qu'avait reçu tous les gens
qui avaient eu une ordonnance et qui
avait été
hospitalisés tout ça a été fait sous le
contrôle d'un huissier de justice
puisque les gens disent qu'on ment donc
on dit qu'on cache les choses donc
toutes ces données sont des données qui
sont extérieures à l'IHU pour savoir le
résultat du traitement de l'HU parce que
on peut tout tricher sur sur les
résultats les gens disent il est allé en
RA il est pas allé en RA moi je peux
vous dire même le passage en RA était
dépendant du réanimateur qui était là il
y en a qui nous les prenaient il y en a
qui n les prenaient pas au début il
voulaient pas nous prendre les plus de
70 ans après il nous prenait même les 80
ans donc c'est pas une donnée qui est
une donnée objective la donnée la seule
donnée objective qui pas d'une grande
geté c'est la mort mais la mort là aussi
on peut savoir alors les gens peuvent
tricher ces gens qui disent je je je les
crois pas une seconde nous pour regarder
qui est mort qui est pas mort on a
regardé l'INC c'est-à-dire que on a une
liste maintenant des 34000 personnes qui
ont été traitées on a comparé ça avec
les gens qui étaient morts dans les 3
mois après le diagnostic qui avait été
fait dans l'IHU et on sait exactement
combien il y a de gens qui sont morts de
ça parmi les gens qui étaient
hospitalisés donc qui avaient besoin
d'oxygène et qui étaient grave don l'âge
moyen de mortalité était de 81 ans il y
a eu 7 % de mort d'accord d'accord qui
est la plus basse série au monde tout
est vérifiable je demande depuis 1 an et
demi à la NSM et à Ligas de venir
vérifier nos chiffres il y a un huissier
de justice qui met son métier sur la
table là que l'on va payer pour vérifier
tout alors ça c'est raisonnable pourquoi
ils l'ont pas fait ça professeur par
mais parce qu'ils connaissent bien le
résultat ouais donc pourquoi pourquoi on
sort des choses comme ça pourquoi c'est
ce chiffre qui a énormément circulé par
exemple des gens comme Géraldine maillet
qui est très
sympa elle s'est frotté les mains quand
elle a entendu ça donc quand vous
entendez la réponse de av il est sorti
exactement dans les très contemp il est
sorti dans les 3 mois précédents deux
études une étude italienne une étude
belge qui trouvait ex ex les mêmes
proportions de protection de la mort que
la nôtre don vous avez pas parlé mais
qu'est-ce que vous dites au profil de
raou ben moi je je vous écoute déjà
professur on ferme sa gueule non pas du
tout déjà je savais pas qu'on avait le
droit de parler au professeur RA parce
que je sais que Monsieur monsieur vous
n'aimez pas forcément la contradiction
et moi je pourrais pas me permettre de
vous contredire parisque vous êtes un
éminent professeur et je suis une simple
chroniqueuse donc je n'ai pas évidemment
votre compétence et je ne serit pas au
niveau pour vous contredire d'un point
de vue médical en revanche c'est vrai
que moi quand la crise du covid est de
en 19 en en c'était en 2020 maintenant
moi évidemment je vous ai vu comme
beaucoup j'imagine comme l'homme
prévident providentielle c'est-à-dire
que vraiment j'étais complètement dans
la Raoul Mania vraiment vous étiez pour
moi une chance et un espoir pour cette
maladie et et après effectivement je
vous ai plus du tout cru mais en fait
parce que je ne suis pas une
scientifique donc en fait je crois ou je
ne crois pas donc je crois en ce que
voilà et comme vous avez pas de manière
de de de savoir ce qui est vrai et ce
qui est pas vrai vous croyez un peu ce
que vous voulez non je crois non je
crois mon médecin en revanche qui dit
exactement le contraire de vous alors il
a peut-être pas votre parcours il a
peut-être pas votre notoré oui je sais
que c'est
mais non mais je sais que vous
considérez tous les médecins comme des
ignares je connais plein de
médecins laissez-moi laissez-moi vous
expliquer éout maintenant
écoutez je peux vous dire 90 m pour des
médecins qui parlent de l'hydroxycline
n' connaissent et je vais vous le
prouver ni la DO ni l'efficacité ni la
manière dont on l'utilise il se trouve
si vous prenez n'importe quel livre il
compris le livre des infectiologues
français qui m'ont tellement ennuyé qui
s'appelle le pili est le livre de
maladie infectieuse n'importe quel livre
de maladie infectieuse au monde depuis
25 ans rapporte mon usage de
l'hydroxychloroquine dans des maladies
particulire la chièvre cul maladie de
whiple sa paologie sa toxicité c'est
entièrement connu et c'est la dose que
j'ai utilisé qui est de 600 mg par jour
ce qui s'est passé dans les je pense que
vous allez pouvoir comprendre ce que je
vous dis j'ai essayer je je je vais
envoyer je vous promet c'est pas s parce
que je suis pas vraiment au niveau
contrairement à Miriam qui comprend tout
bien sûr non mais vous vous disputerz
après c'est votre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
problème je vais vous expliquer quelque
chose de simple dans les maladies
infeceus ça fait longtemps que je les
maladies infectieuses dans les maladies
infectieuses les choses commencent par
un diagnostic c'est il faut savoir si le
malade a la maladie ou non l'étude de
base qui a été utilisée partout y
compris par l'OMS c'est une étude
anglaise qui s'appelle recoverie et et
qui a été l'étude qui qui a fait la loi
surtout dans l'étude
recoverie pour inclure les malades
c'estàd pour rentrer les malades dans le
protocole il n'était pas nécessaire de
faire un diagnosticque de covid le
médecin décidé je crois que c'est un
covid je n'ai jamais vu de ma vie une
étude scientifique faite comme ça et
d'ailleurs il l'annonce est écrit si
vous savez lire l'anglais vous le lirez
15 % des gens qui ont été inclus n'ont
pas eu de test PCR voilà on sait pas ce
qu'il deuxièmement quel est le
traitement qu'il leur ont donné le
traitement qu' leur ont donné c'est
écrit auss suffit de le lire hein le
traitement qu'il leur ont donné le
premier jour c'est 2,4 g
d'hydroxychloroquide et ensuite si vous
avz c'est plus facile parce que c'est du
français si vous avez toujours le temps
irrégulier quand même de lire vous vous
lirez la thèse de notre ancien ministre
qui s'appelle Brown qui a fait sa thèse
sur la toxicité de
l'hydroxychloroquine et il marque à
partir de 2,5 g par jour
d'hydroxychloroquine
l'hydroxychloroquine peut devenir
toxique elle est très toxique quand on
en donne 10 g mais à partir de 2,5 g par
jour elle devient toxique tout ça c'est
des données de base c'est-à-dire que des
choses comme ça aent pu être publié et
pu devenir des articles de référence
c'est un truc qui est stupéfiant quant à
ce qui s'est passé sur l'étude de l'OMS
je vous le dire ouais donc encore une
fois moi j'ai fait à peu près 10000
dosages hydroxyclloroquine dans ma vie
dans mon laboratoire parce que les gens
ne savait pas le faire on m'envoyait les
deux es hydroxycocin de toute la France
et du monde entier parce que les gens ne
savait pas doser hydroxychloroine on a
même publié une méthode de de de
simplifieré de de dosage
hydroxychloroine qu'est-ce qui a été
fait en en en France dans le cadre de ce
qu'ils ont appelé Discovery c'est parce
qu'ils ont découvert au lieu de faire
comme les Anglais qui avaient donné
quatre fois la dose ils ont donné les 2/
de la dose c'estàd ils ont donné 400 mg
au lieu de donné 600 mg moi ça fait 30
ans que que j'écris que je donne 600 mg
par jour pendant plus d'un an aux gens
et je vais vous dire une deuxième chose
mais je je je l'ai déjà dit et puis que
vous me croyez ou que vous me croyez pas
comme comme vous le savez je je m'en
fiche comme dans l'an 40 ça j'imagine
donc vous avez bien raison d'ailleurs on
va les couilles je vois pas pourquoi
votre opinion serait plus importante que
la mienne alors que vous savez pas de
quoi vous parlez moi je sais de quoi je
parle absolument vous avez tout à fait
raison comme nous tous autour de cette
table d'ailleurs le le le
le le même jour je je je suis je suis
toujours pour des raisons qui m'étonnent
le seul consultant éditorial du Land
français il a pas d'autre regarder la
page
du consultante toujours mon
problème s tout ce que je vous dis vous
pouvez toujours le regarder enregistrez
vous allez voir si vous lisez pas tout
en anglais vous le faites traduire sur
Google c'est
instantané vous laene vraiment le même
le même non je sais pas lui il m'a dit
ça lui m'a dit ça moi je m'en fous je
vous tout ce que je dis je connais des
grands médecins professeur que vous
connaissez
je ce que vous connaissez je m'en fous
c'est grand médecin ça ve rien dire moi
je fais 1,85 un grand
médec sauf que vous avez échoué sur le
covid et je comprends que ce soit très
très dur pour vous d'avaler ça alors que
vous êtes un professeur
brans sur le covid en
fait
vous mais vous faites th là Mad moi je
je je pas vous faites mais c'est du moi
je fais pas de thâre j'essaie de vous
alors pourquoi vous acceptez pas de
répondre avec vos à des confrères
médecins parce que c'est facile moi de
me démonter je suis une chroniqueuse je
su pas médecin pourquoi vous acceptez
pas de parler à à des médecins qui sont
pas d'accord avec vous à vos détracteurs
sur des plateau
télécep tout ce que je fais pourquoi
vous acceptez pas parce laiss parler
parce que parce que vous
vous vous faites dans les gens qui sont
chez vous ils ont peut-être tous le même
niveau que vous moi je je je c'est bien
possible donc vous
pou j'en sais rien mais vous pouvez par
vous ça avec un peu de mépris comme si
je une
débile moi moi vous
savez ça fait 20 ans que je suis le
microbiologiste le plus dans les débil
dans les débiles comme moi il y en a qui
achètent votre livre donc vous devriez
pas les méprise je vous méprise pas je
vous dis simplement que vous vous
comparez des gens qui ne sont pas
comparable j'ai ça fait depuis 20 j'ai
été dans le l'éditorial bord de tous les
journaux de maladiie infectieuses du
monde savoir je suis le plus cité depuis
20 ans de tous les microbiologies du
monde et que donc quand vous avez un
pharmacocinéticien qui découvre la
maladie infectieuse et qui n'a jamais
soigné un malade et qui veut me donner
une leçon je lui parle pas voilà
exactement c'est pas compliqué par pas
au G qui qui mais mais qui je vais
parler à un néphrologue raté je vais
parler à quoi à qui je vais parler vous
avez non mais enfin vous avez vu qui
vous entendz mais qui vous invitaz mais
vous avez pas honte ou enfin vous
invitez des gens mais il faut inviter
qui pour être digne du professeur raou
alors votre reflet en fait dans un
miroir il faut inviter qui en fait non
non mais moi ce que je je je vos types
de débat d'ailleurs je je je je je
regrette de me retrouver dans ce type de
débat parce que je je parle pas avec les
gens comme vous d'habitude je le fais
pas j' bien compris je je je je parle
pas dans les bistros non plus voyez donc
je je vous parler à Cyril alors parce
que lui il est digne de vous alors mais
c'est vous qui me parler moi je vous ai
rien
demandé enfin vousz qu'à garder votre
opinion pour vous moi je m'en fous
parler avec votre maman votre cousine
votre concierge je m'en fous ça
m'intéresse pas soyez pas méprisent ma
concierge elle vous adore par exemple ah
B voilà je beaucoup qui intelligence il
y en a beaucoup qui adore le professeur
pris en tout cas et en pratique en tout
cas et en
pratique le même pour que je puisse fin
de parler si vous acceptez de pas
m'interrompre pour me raconter les
choses qui ne m'intéresse
guerre la même semaine pour le Land 7
cyez pas impressionn quand même de la
même semaine pour le l j'envoie moi un
article qui était les 3700 premières
personnes que nous avions testé cet
article le l 7 ne le lit pas alors
qu'encore une fois je je je connais très
bien
en même temps le L7 m'envoie un article
à review dans cet article à review dont
vous n'avez jamais entendu parler mais
que vous pouvez retrouver puisque
maintenant il est publié dans un journal
qui s'appelle l'ancêre
rumatologie les rhumatologues du monde
entier l'hydroxychloroquine vous savez
ça a été utilisé par des milliards de
personnes pour traiter le le paludisme
et par des centaines de millions de
personnes pour traiter le lupus et la PO
us à ces poologies là très bien ils
envoient un article en disant nous
allons voir si l'hydroxychloroine est
associé là c'est pas trois ozo qui ont
jamais vu de malade c'est on va voir si
l'hydroxychloroine donne plus de mort
que le traitement alternatif de la
polyartrite rhumatoïde je demanderez à
vos grands médecins SS ont entendu
parler de ces médicaments qui est la
sulfadiasine d'accord 1 million dans
chaque bras
ouais il n'y a pas de sur mortalité avec
l'hydroxychloroine comparé à la
sulfadiazine don jamais personne 1
million dans chaque bras je donne un
avis très favorable écoutez c'est
vraiment c'est très intéressant parce
que quand vous avez traité 1 million de
personnes les rhumatologue il traite pas
pendant 10 jours comme n traité il
pendant 1 an 2 ans 3 ans 4 ans quand
vous avez 1 million de gens traités qui
n'ont aucun accident
cardiovasculaire ça a un sens ce qui se
passe c'est que le l 7 dans dans un
premier temps ne le prend pas il prendra
dans un des bébés duf qui s'appelle l'an
rumatologie où il est publié vous avez
qu'à regarder tout ça c'est de la
littérature et enfin en même temps le
Land qui n'a pas envoyé à revouv publie
un papier qui est l gate dans lequel ils
annoncent qu'ils ont traité 80000
personnes dont la promotrice c'est une
ancienne p star
qui ouou c'est beau elle est magnif
les cordonn
pourM et ils annoncent 10 % de mort et
avec un truc extraordinaire c'est
là-dessus ça c'est publié le vendredi je
vous raconte des choses vous avez qu'à
les lire c'est tout écrit ça ch il a
raison
l c'est écrit le vendredi moi j'ai un
ami à l'Élysée qui me dit Didier tu peux
me donner ton avis sur ce papier ouais
Thierry couon c'est pas un mystère je
dis écoute c'est gentil je je passe le
weekend parce que je passe pas SEM à
travailler je te réponds lundi ouais le
lundi je regarde l'article et
entreetemps Verant avait dit la
chlorquine tue on arrête tout le
directeur de l'OMS avait dit la
chlorquine tue on arrête tout je lis ce
papier qui est un tissu d'annerie inouï
dans lequel on avait fait je pense que
vous devez sa si vous savez pas vous
demanderez au grand médecin que vous
connaissez mais les dans lequel on dit
voilà on a des données partout dans la
France d'ailleurs et on a étudié comment
on le fait aux États-Unis parce qu'on a
le droit de le faire aux États-Unis mais
en France on n pas le droit de le faire
on dit alors quelle est l'ethnie des
patients en France qui ont eu cette
maladie et qui en sont morts c'est
illégal on n pas le droit de mettre sur
un papier lui il est maghrébain lui il
est juif lui il est on n pas le droit
c'est interdit en France d'accord donc
c'est un c'est une fausse
australiens en même temps en disant mais
il disent qu'ils ont plus de covid dans
le série qu'il n a eu de covid dans
toute l'Australie
d'c moiécrit une lettre qui est
acceptépr pas publ parce que l'article
sera rétracté donc on va pas publier les
lettres sur les articles existent plus
il y a une une série tout des
infectiolog Anglais écriv en demandant
est-ce que vous êtes devenu complètement
fou qui a review ça et l'article est
retiré et là-dessus la décision qui
avait été prise et qui est toujours
parce que le Land l' rétracté mais
l'article est toujours disponible il est
toujours cité des centaines de fois
d'accord et si vous faites euh euh la
bêtise artificielle vous allez trouver
la bêtise artificielle bien sûr cet
article a été rétracté mais il mentionne
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de morts làans
voilà et donc moi ma seule réponse à moi
c'est elle est pas compliqué je je je
vais pas aller jouer avec des gens qui
n'ont vu aucun malade qui sont allés
pêcher dans les 1000 ù il y a il y a eu
3000 à peu près 2500 études qui ont été
faites sur le traitement du covid si
vous voulez vraiment au lieu de demander
au grand médecin que vous connaissez
vous regardez un site qui s'appelle
early C19 marquez-le marquez-le early
c19.com vous regardez ce soir voilà
20300 ils regardent tous les médicaments
qui ont été utilisés et contre quoi ils
ont été utilisés vous avez des données
qui tombe d'une manière absolument
étonnante exactement sur le même donné
que nous donné précocément il y a 70 %
de protection de la mortalité donné
tardivement il y a 40 % de protection de
la mortalité voilà le reste après vous
pouvez toujours trouver un coUignon qui
écrit une série de bêtises et ne lire
que celui-là plutôt que de lire tous
ceux qui ont écrit la mer les Belges
sont fous parce qu'ils ont dit que
c'était ça en Belgique ils ont sorti à 2
mois un papier qui dit le contraire et
qui dit que ça marche très bien les
Espagnols sont fous les Italiens sont
fous tous les les gens qui ont des
données
vérifiables et donc j'espère bien qu'à
la suite de cette affaire là c'est pour
ça que je me fiche complètement et de de
ce que les uns et les autres
racontent en général je veux pas dire
vous en particulier mais en général
parce que j'espère que ce que nous avons
fait va devenir une règle c'est déjà en
train de le devenir c'est-à-dire qu'on
ne pourra pas publier de série sans
donner sans déposer sur un site
l'ensemble de ces données ce que nous
avons publié comme on a été menacé à
deux reprises par le ministre ce que
nous avons publié nous avons mis
l'ensemble des données qui sont
vérifiées par l'issier sur deux banques
de données internationales une chinoise
et une américaine pour que tout le monde
puisse aller vérifier tout ce que nous
avons tout ce que nous avons dit donc
j'ai pas de problème avec ça que je moi
je cherche ni à faire l'unanimité ni à
vous plaire je je je je vois même plus
de malade alors j'ai pas de raison de
vous
voir je je vois je soigne plus les gens
donc j'ai pas de raison je encore une
fois je m'en fiche que vous me croyez ou
pas moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
faire mon métier je fais mon métier
quand il y a des gens qui remettent en
cause un certain nombre de choses que
j'ai faites je prends les données
précises de la littérature des gens
sérieux je regarde qui a fait quoi et
puis je regarde comment nous nous avons
été amenés nous à faire des choix de
cette nature moi je suis sidéré que les
les les je vais vous dire les deux
essais français ont été arrêtés au
moment de de du ceux qui étaiit en cours
les deux essai randomisés il y en avait
un qui s'appelait recovery et l'autre
qui été fait par anger les deux ont été
arrêtés par Verant au moment du LAN gate
il a jamais voulu revenir dessus alors
qu'il y avait temp pourquoi mais parce
que il voulait pas cont
par il est 21h18 tu demandes pourquoi
toi av des
médic répond non mais s'il y avait des
médicament vas-y
21ans pourtant ces deux études et je
l'ai publié aussi dans ces deux études
il y avait moins de morts chez les gens
qui avaient pris l'hydroxychloroine que
ceux qui n'avaient pas et alors la
raison pour la qui a été évoquée par
l'iner à l'époque c'est pour futilité
bien fait il l' arrêté pour futilité je
sais pas le terme futilité ils ont que
c'était futile de continuer vous vouz la
raison c'est futilité et liner m'a
refusé quand il y a eu l'enquête auprès
de l'Assemblée nationale a refusé de
transmettre les chiffres quand ils ont
été demandés par celui qui faisit
l'investigation taeule
toi la réponse qui a été donnée ça sera
publiéc merci je vouis vous dire merci
vous savez que êtes toujours bienvenu
ici vous savez que je suis fan de vous
et que vraiment vous êtes mon invité
préféré sachez-le et voilà Géraldine tu
es contente de des répondre de
professeur importe ça lu est égal en
tout je me suis régalé voilà je dis
encore ce soir ça ce livre incroyable ni
angélique ni diabolique les
antibiotiques iraou ça je lis tous les
gens qui viennent ici celui-là ti je te
l'ofre celui-là ti tu vois au lieu de
d'être sur la médecine tu ferais mieux
d'être sur les meurtrres merci
professeur raou d'avoir été avec
nous